foreign
[Music]
my name is Ellis Hughes and as you can
tell probably from this title slide here
I work at GSK I'm a data science leader
in the statistical data sciences and
Innovation Hub same as Becca who
presented earlier uh and we're
responsible for Innovation and uh
developing of our packages to try to
improve processes and whatnot so I
thought I'd come here today to talk
about that a little bit
so I think sorry uh I think we've all
worked on a process before that promised
the world that it was supposed to solve
all our problems make make our lives
just substantially easier and it didn't
do that in fact it made it harder it
made it tougher made it slower you're
confused the entire time
and I call those edsels
do you know what an Edsel is
the Edsel is the automotive world's
biggest flop
so I'm going to tell you a little bit of
a story about the Edsel so in 1957 Ford
is hinting about the next car that
they're going to be producing the car of
the future is going to be they've spent
10 years developing this thing
250 million dollars of 1950s money which
is 2.5 billion dollars today
and it's supposed to be this Fantastical
thing that's gonna you know take us all
into the future and it's going to be
full of technologies that are going to
make our lives easier
in 1958 the dead Soul arrives with a lot
of fanfare
there they've got advertisements all
over the world or all over the states
they've got a TV show about the a TV
show about the Edsel of all things and
it's got all this wonderful technology
like in your steering wheel you can
select your gear you don't have to gear
shift it's just in your ceiling it's
right there for you on the dashboard
there's a button that squirts oil on
your front suspension to keep it from
squeaking isn't that amazing
but in 1959 they kill it it's done it's
no longer out there anymore
in 1960 the last Edsel rolls off the
line
this is a screen capture from a Times
magazine where it's the wrong car the
wrong place the wrong time
but what happened from 1957 where it's
the car of the future it's supposed to
be doing everything for us to 1959
instead it's gone stop asking about it
well there are a couple different
problems with the Edsel first Edsel was
designed by committee there was no real
why driving the development of the Edsel
other than it's the car of the future
it's got to have everything it's going
to be fantastic
during this time also Ford was going
through some restructuring some changing
and so a lot of different Executives
were in charge of this project over the
10 years it was being developed of
course so they all wanted to put their
thumbprint on the Edsel to enable to uh
you know push their careers forward
without really paying respect to what is
this supposed to be what are we trying
to actually accomplish here
and then as I alluded to earlier 10
years of development so when it was
first released they were all in on this
there were 18 different models that were
available for people not including
colors internal trims all those other
things this was just all the models that
were available for the Edsel
then going on the idea of there was no
real why behind it there were no real
requirements or constraints when they
were designing it so the car design the
Horseshoe that you saw at the front
there was thought to be really ugly and
in fact people didn't like the way that
it looked now I don't really think it
looks too bad but you know whatever
and then there also had a bunch of
technology that didn't really solve any
problems for us it was technology
technological solutions that were
searching for a problem they're trying
to identify that you know those
automatic gear shift selector and the
steering wheel people hated it you know
what you're used to in the center of
your steering wheel a horn
they hit the horn and they've actually
accidentally changed gears
in addition there was a lot of QA and QC
issues related to all those
technological solutions they weren't
really meant to be in production that
early and that led to issues where they
were the the factory was sending
incomplete cars to their dealerships
with just all the different pieces that
they didn't complete just sitting in the
boot
waiting for the dealerships to sort this
out
and so that's why of many other reasons
the Edsel failed
but how can we take lessons from this
and keep our next project from becoming
the next Edsel
so I'm going to go through a little case
study of a project that we worked on uh
where we identified a slow process that
we wanted to fix
so inside of our Pro inside of our
organization we have a programming team
that does all our data analysis and data
prep
the process this data they do all this
formatting and they've output to several
different files and intending for
Downstream users to use this to generate
reports and presentations and reports
and whatnot
uh these Downstream users take this they
statisticians will generate reports or
presentations and our medical writers
will generate reports of differing
levels of programming backgrounds and
whatnot the issue with this is our
programmers are generating data in
formats that are Downstream users
couldn't use directly
that meant that there was a lot of
manual reproducing of data a lot of copy
and paste from the format that we were
producing into their PowerPoint and Word
Documents
when people are copying and pasting that
leads to formatting inconsistencies like
oh I'll just delete that I don't wait I
don't like the way that percent looks
I'll just put it at the top there or I
want more spacing here I want to merge
these columns not fundamentally changing
the data but the way it's displayed
and because we're doing all this copy
and pasting and reformatting we have to
do a lot of really intense QC on data
we've already generated and already qc'd
to make sure that we're not showing
anything that's incorrect so there's all
this effort going into this process that
is just we're not producing the correct
data we're not working we're not talking
together to make sure that everything
works together nicely
but we saw this as you know what that's
not a bad thing that's an opportunity
for us to step in and help and try to
improve the process because the data is
being used by the same Downstream user
or the same data are being used by the
downstream users we can use this as a
starting point and try to build
processes and build a package to try to
make their lives easier
next we found out and learned about
packages have come out like the office
first which is a series of packages by
David goel that interact with Office
Products and help you write your ooxml
to allow you to inject and work with
your word and PowerPoint package or
presentations and documents and whatnot
so officer and there's also Flex table
which is a package that helps you make
tables into Powerpoints and Word
Documents kind of seems like it'll be
pretty useful for us
so before we really went and just went
all all Full Tilt to develop anything we
wanted to make sure we had a full set of
expectations so we understood what we
were trying to build before we went to
go build it
so if we're designing a new workflow we
want to create collaboration that was
the that was what was causing problems
before between our programmers
statisticians and medical writers we
wanted to work with our existing systems
we don't want to have to try to create
and roll up a new system what do we have
that what can we reuse
where can we extract the data from how
can we pull from existing streams
we're already using PowerPoint and docx
so let's output to that let's not make
our end users relearn everything
and then as we generate these inputs
let's automatically tag those because
you can use comments in PowerPoint and
docx tag those with comments of hey
you're going to need to QC this this was
generated you know custom
and then ultimately this process
originally was very slow
we want to introduce the timeline into
less than a week
then as we went to go develop the team
now that we had our expectations we had
a team of very a small team of
experienced individuals that were both
understood the process what they were
trying to replace as well as understood
what they were generating or how to
program this is important so we
understood what were the constraints
what could we feasibly make or not make
we had a single point decision maker
they were ultimately responsible for
making a call if there was a
disagreement
then we worked with the experts the
people that were using our Downstream
users as well as Upstream users to
Define okay what are the core things
that we need to create what are the
features that need to be on the roadmap
eventually we didn't maybe don't need
them immediately But ultimately they did
not have the final decision they weren't
the executives at four that were telling
us what to do they were saying hey it'd
be really nice if
we try to simplify things we didn't want
to try to recreate the wheel like I said
we didn't want to recreate systems so
let's use existing tools let's use
Office first rather than trying to make
our home cooked version of office first
to interact with the XML and PowerPoint
and docx let's let's use the tools that
already exist and try to maybe improve
it as we need to
um
people were adding their own standards
and their own changes to the outputs so
let's revert back to what are the
standards what exactly is it that we
have to make and then we can maybe
iterate from there
and then identify areas of common rework
by the staff what are the common
reformatting that is being done and can
we do this programmatically is it
reasonable to do it programmatically
what are things that we need to
capitalize or lower case or change
while we developed this too we wanted to
watch our scope
so we wanted to make sure that the
system could grow as we needed to change
as we needed the world is a changing
Place let's try to keep that in mind
the feature requests that we got we
would compare them against the
feasibility of doing that once again can
we do this programmatically should we be
doing this programmatically or should
should we push back and go maybe this
isn't this isn't the time
we also have limited resources we have a
small team of people working on this so
that made us keep in mind that
everything that we did was in strict
adherence to the goals what are we
actually trying to achieve and try to
push away things this might sound a
little bit familiar this is kind of
agile I don't know if you've ever heard
of that that's pretty popular uh
so I'm happy to report that this
actually this project did turn out
pretty well we've reduced the reporting
time significantly things we've been
able to generate reports in under a week
There's no programming skills required
by our non-programming staff they are
not required to write any programming
we're able to generate their reports
using the programmers and then just
running it through this tool that we've
created and as everyone else in Pharma
it is validated
per our internal process
so the reason this project succeeded I I
believe I named a couple of those as
well we established our requirements we
knew what our outputs were we knew what
we were trying to create and we didn't
deviate from that
we knew what our measurement of success
was we knew if we achieved this goal we
succeeded and anything that we did was
only in trying to achieve that goal
we were Relentless when people asked us
to do new feature add new features we'd
go okay do you need this now or is this
something can happen later
we kept perspective of the values that
we were adding and tried once again it's
all all about not doing things we don't
need to do don't add unnecessary things
unless you need to cool and then also
single point decision making ultimately
one person had to make a call
okay
I'm going to close with a final story
from the same company Ford
and we're going to make a GT not an
Edsel
so 1966 Ford wins the world renowned
hardest race in the racing world the 24
Hours of Le Mans which is a race where
people drive for 24 hours and the winner
is determined not by how many laps they
do but how far they drive this is a true
endurance test of the quality of your
car how good is it made how well did you
design this
the impressive thing about this for this
is the second year Ford had ever
competed in Le Mans they'd never
competed in a competed in it before
the prior winner had been Ferrari who'd
won for the last six years and has a
long history in racing
so how did Ford go from a company that
made a thing like the Edsel
to the GT and won the whole darn thing
in their second year of competing
well they had a small dedicated team
they uh they set out to beat Ferrari
that was their goal in mind not just
when for uh the 24 hours of the month
but let's beat Ferrari
they get they got together a set of a
small team Carol Shelby and Ken miles
who had a history of success doing this
sort of thing Carol Shelby was an old
racer so he used to race he actually won
Le Mans I think a decade or two before
and started his own car company called
Shelby America you might know him from
the Shelby Cobra
as well as Ken miles who had been a
successful driver in Britain uh bracing
various uh cars of various degrees
and then everything they did for the
next two years was focused on results
what could they do to make the GT faster
how could they win Le Mans
they've worked through aerodynamics they
had a initial concept they did they
constantly drove around they had their
drivers that were going to be in the
race drive the car around give feedback
to the engineers even this is a picture
of the engineers and drivers with little
pieces of string that they taped onto
the uh the GT to see how aerodynamics
worked and if there are any areas of low
pressure that they would need to address
and they trusted the driver's experience
in addition to that they push
Technologies forward they took the
Ford's proven racing engine from Nascar
and improved it they made it faster they
made it stronger they took existing
Technologies and made better and they
also innovated they took the quick chain
or they invented a quick change brake
pads and rotors the EGT was a very heavy
car they break a lot in LeMans or they
have to press the brake pad so they
needed a quick way to redo this so they
created new technologies in order to
solve the problems at hand and that was
all they were ever focused on how can we
do this faster how can we do this better
so I'm going to end with this projects
the packages should be designed with
purpose and be relentless in pursuing
their goals that's how you make a good
packaging process
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]